that's the good and evil we're back to
the good and evil so maybe we should go
back to church
look the priest did some weird stuff but
maybe we it's good people in there more
than evil people well the problem is
with that Church in particular there's
still shielding the people that have
done terrible things yeah yeah there's
just no denying that there's if you look
at the facts if you look at everything
that's come out if there's no denying
that no it's a super unfortunate because
I think the vast majority of the people
that are involved in the religion that
aren't the people that are pedophiles
right I think they're very good people
that probably think about it the same
way maybe your daughter would like to
think about it that someplace where
people can get together and they
exchange affection and camaraderie and
and this acceptance of something higher
than them that holds them to a certain
standard and wants them to be good
people and that's good for everybody
good for everybody but if it wasn't for
all that kid [ __ ] yeah all that kid
[ __ ] just ruined all that it just
yeah yeah it really really is such a sad
sad thing Google this because I've said
this many times and I've never bothered
looking it up that uh they're the reason
why we can get another bottle that if
you want to get [ __ ] up ok it's the
holidays okay so holidays
what were we just talking about good and
evil and the the priests and why they're
ruining in Iran you said go give that
video with something up you haven't
looked before a reason why oh that's it
thank you thought that was gone forever
I voted the reason why they forced
priest to be celibate because what I had
heard how was it son and this is not no
scholarly work of my own I don't
remember even reading the article I
think somebody told it to me that
priests were banging too many chicks you
might have said it that way too many
chicks man they made a mess out of it
which I think I don't think that was it
what do you think it is I think it was
property I think that when priests
priests owned property and if they were
married and he died she would keep the
property hmm
if there was no woman involved and he
owned the property and he couldn't be
with a woman
and he swore that he was just with Jesus
when he died the property went to the
church yeah yeah that's you know which
is not much of I mean that's crazy
it's wow that whole other part of
Catholicism is the other thing that
bumps me all the time when you go to the
Vatican it's like wow this is beautiful
but what where'd they get all this art
where'd they get all these build I mean
yeah the pillaging of [ __ ] of raelians
dollars were the [ __ ] all stolen from a
time where people are starving this tree
know this is how powerful religion is
this is how powerful this pull is to
search for good and to be a part of
something is that we're in light of
those things that you you see the wealth
it's like going into like a pirate ship
and seeing all the [ __ ] that they got
and then knowing what they do with these
children both those things are you
should just say no [ __ ] this I'm gonna
be I'm not gonna be a part of this at
all yeah but the the the other part of
it is so strong that you actually will
kind of say well yeah yeah yeah but I'm
still gonna go to Mass on Sunday I think
you know what happens you think that
even if a priest is bad that the
religion is still good you know right
the idea is this is like a bad guy who
lost his way that this sort of human
beings that are flawed yeah a lot of
them are drunk two men my grandma's my
grandma's eulogy you know her name was
Josephine but he kept calling her
Geraldine correct its Josephine like he
was pretty was saying all these great
things about her he knows I know and he
had those Jim blossoms Oh Jamie brought
another bottle of wine I'm like savage
Savage Jamie Jamie but I think you know
you take a guy and you put him in that
position where he can't have a companion
like you're not allowed to have a love
ya can't have a wife or a husband or
whatever you can't have that it's a
horrible thing to do fighting nature
there's a kid that I went to high school
with
became a priest yeah we all knew he was
gay oh yeah I'll know like it was it was
like a thing you know like oh this is
why he's gonna be a priest we get it
right well that's what a lot of people
say it's like that the church the other
side of us that the church doesn't
create pedophiles that like the
institution attracts them because they
know they'll be safe there well it's
it's possible but it's also possible
that so many of them that are active in
the church and I don't know what this
guy story was I barely knew him yeah but
that he could have been molested I mean
this is not it's not a small number of
kids that were molested it's a very
large large yeah and you would never
mean who the [ __ ] understands what that
would be like to be a young boy to have
that happen to you and then get groomed
and indoctrinated into being a part of
this thing that does that to other young
boys in the future it's your whole
reality which has to be with some of
them are and they're all doing this
under the blanket of this thing called
the church then when the church finds
out about it the church moves people to
all these different various places and
they they get these new victims yeah and
this happens over and over and over
again you know this is one of the things
that they were saying about benedict
about the one who read before or cool
POTUS yeah yeah yeah he had actively
done that you know he was always people
yeah it was a part of that bad so bad
and it's such a shame married Catholic
priests there perhaps 120 in the u.s.
already here's how whoa is this a new
thing yeah
the other article I found said there's
about 200 Wow
as of 1980 there was a rule change or an
adoption of a rule change that allowed
is why does it say does it say Eastern
only is that what it's saying that was
something in the story or the video that
was going yeah but it's kind of positive
why I say Eastern Catholic like east
coast East Coast like west coast not
Mexicans are not buying married in the
house huh 120 Catholic priests married
in the United States wow that was great
policy changed by pope john paul ii in
1980 which offered
half for married Episcopal priest to
continue their ministry after converting
to Catholicism oh so you have to be a
priest already if you're a Episcopalian
and then you're allowed to have a wife
and kids if you're Episcopalian right
yeah for sure I love them convert to
Catholicism is the only one that doesn't
allow them to have sex right yeah it's
the only one with this littered with kid
[ __ ] right exactly cut the [ __ ] we
were we are actually at Mass and he was
talking about there was one thing from
the gospel that was talking about being
married being with a woman and then he
finishes her answer happy holidays
he finishes the he finishes the sermon
and then he the reading then he goes
into a sermon all about being with a
woman and this is a man that doesn't
come close to that this is a man that
has no experience it would be so much
better for the church if he was a
married man with children and then he
could really talk about being in a
family like who are you you know nothing
about what we're dealing with on a daily
basis